with Kevin Frazier and Cassidy gift for
this little bit sad well Cameron worse
and because it's time for Cassidy to
head back to Los Angeles but it has been
a blast hanging out with you at media
day slash opening night and of course
here at the visa everywhere lounge thank
you so much Kathy no Kevin thank you and
thank you to everyone Entertainment
Tonight I have the most incredible time
I got to tell you this I know your mom's
been watching and I know your dad is one
also remind everybody tonight on CBS
it's Super Bowls greatest commercial
special and part of the show is a
reunion between Mean Joe green and the
coca-cola kid and here's a little taste
yeah want my coke 36 years later we
reunite Joe with the Navarone Tommy
Oakland what was it like to meet Joe
first contact probably a little scary
there's a big guy
still spit the two-hour special is
hosted by boomers - and katharine mcphee
this year's show we have Arnold
Schwarzenegger it's going to be a part
of it also part of it a new victoria's
secret spot called score more for models
suit up and Erin Andrews is the coach
within the games turnover we need to
force a turnover